we haven't even seen a picture of her
yet
but baby lillabet diana mountbatten
windsor
more specifically her name is already
making headlines
with conflicting stories about when the
queen was asked permission
or just told by harry and megan they
were using her nickname
the palace adding to that confusion by
not denying claims
that she was never asked some would
argue that even though they're now
in america an expectation of protocol is
inevitable when the great grandmother is
the monarch
royals call their children by other
royal names that's what royals do so we
see the same names returning through
royal history
william ann charles henry phillip
so for example princess usually recently
called her son
philip as a middle name lillabet became
the queen's nickname from an early age
it was the way that she pronounced
elizabeth
an affectionate pet name that was then
used by prince philip
and only those closest to her a
spokesperson for the sussexes told sky
news that the queen was the first member
of the family that harry called ahead of
the announcement
and that he shared their hope of naming
her lillabet in her honor
if she hadn't been supportive they would
not have used the name
we're also told prince harry spoke to
other members of the family before the
announcement
prince charles the first to speak about
the newest edition during a speech about
the importance of green fuel
he's vital for maintaining the health of
our world
for future generations something i'm
only
too aware of today having recently
become a grandfather for the fifth time
after a difficult 18 months where the
split in the family has played out so
publicly
carolyn durant who co-wrote the book
finding freedom about the sussexes
says this latest confusion isn't helpful
in all of our families there are ups and
downs but
that we're discussing
[Music]
a beautiful little girl's arrival
into the world and making it an issue i
think is quite sad
actually i think it's sad for the family
and what could be a really
wonderful happy moment that has the
ability to
bring the family closer
the choice of royal baby names is so
often left
open to guesswork but after a fractious
time for the family
a lack of clarity has turned lillabet's
name into more of a story
than it was ever intended to be and that
is likely to cause frustration
on both sides rhiannon mills sky news